Hi, everybody!
I think we’re gonna have some fun.
Talk about some hard stuff,
laugh a little bit, and hopefully
learn something from each other.
How many of you know
that I’m super introverted?
It’s handy when I’m traveling
because, like,
I’ll be sitting next to someone
and they’ll say,
“So, what do you do?”
And if I’m not in the mood to chat,
I’ll be like,
“I study shame. What do you do?”
They’re just like...
How many of you want more love,
intimacy, joy?
True belonging doesn’t require you
to change who you are.
It requires you to be who you are.
You don’t measure vulnerability
by the amount of disclosure.
Live-tweeting your bikini wax:
not vulnerability.
I’m not going to bullshit you.
Vulnerability is hard, and it’s scary,
and it feels dangerous.
But it’s not as hard or scary or dangerous
as getting to the end of our lives
and having to ask ourselves,
"What if I would’ve shown up?"